berry football club a hundred and thirty
four years old promoted to Ligue 1 last
season but last month the Shakers were
kicked out of the Football League after
getting into financial difficulties
leaving fans devastated the local Labour
MP says the imbalance in football speaks
to a wider imbalance in society we are a
town in the shadow of Manchester we're
proudly part of Greater Manchester but
if you consider bury in the shadow of
Manchester it is also in the shadow of
Manchester clubs and this imbalance
within football speaks to the wider
imbalance in society and so I think
people it does it does pull at the
heartstrings there is a fight beyond
simply keeping Barry Football Club alive
here and I think that's about
Englishness it's about identity it's
about the town's role in the wider
economy but it's also about livelihoods
you've got to feel for the people of
Barry they've just gone through the
heartbreak of seeing their club expelled
from the Football League and now they
face the prospect of politicians
descending here on mass to find a
general election campaign because it's
towns like Barry that will decide who
ends up in number 10 Barry North is a
classic to weigh marginal Labour's James
5th took the seat from the Conservatives
in 2017 but with a 4000 vote majority in
a bricks it supporting area he faces a
battle to keep it at the next election
what do you think about the thought of
having an election I think we should
have an election just because like it's
been so long since we've seen that we're
gonna have a breaks it deal there's been
so many arguments if they can't come to
a conclusion they should definitely be
an election it's it's needed I know he
would you'd be fighting for the local MP
is great yeah the local Labour MP well
stunned it yeah he would enlist time
yeah and he really is good but if you
vote for him you can enjoy me carbon and
does that worry you though very yeah
yeah it'd be a tough between us or talk
between very strong soon a natural fire
chief he came into it so what what is it
that you like about Boris Johnson them I
think is [ __ ] best to get us out in
the EU
hmm I think everyone's been sliding the
feet where he seems to be in there
saying that he'll do it do it yeah you
trust him I don't think an election is
the right way of going let's just do one
job at a time
let's get the brexit or issue sorted out
and let's see how we go and what do you
think of Boris Johnson then gee like him
or you worried about him I liked him a
lot
ages ago but now things are coming to
the forefront and to sack 21 MP esterday
I don't want us to turn into a dick
toriel country the sacking of those 21
MPs but voting against the government
makes Boris Johnson like Barry's own
Robert Peel yet another conservative
prime minister to oversee a major split
in his party Alistair Bert is a former
MP for barry north and was one of the
conservatives stripped to the party whip
this week it's a decision he thinks will
play badly in marginals like Barry I
think moderate voters in Barry will be
will be concerned they don't like
extremism and they will feel something
has gone wrong with a Conservative Party
in Parliament if it doesn't contain
Kenneth Clarke and Nicholas Soames and a
number of others they'll worry about it
and if the reaction is anything like my
emails have been since Tuesday I've had
a number of conservative voters saying
thank you very much for what you did and
we're not going to vote conservative
again so I think the party is going to
take that seriously and I think it would
affect a party that you know my friends
in Barry as well facing losses in
Scotland and the southeast if Boris
Johnson is to have any chance of
securing a majority at the next election
he will need to win seats like Barry
most of the marginal seats that will be
contested next election there in terms
will be in terms of the hundreds up
marginals in 2017 two-thirds
three-quarters were interns and that's
been the same for about a decade
different marginals appear but they're
still predominantly in town
constituencies and so that's why the
mayor
parties are focusing heavily on towns so
we're certainly gonna see Boris Johnson
and Jeremy Corbyn making numerous trips
to towns when that lations absolutely
yeah if you look at the way that lab is
performed in cities and conservatives
perform in rural communities and
constituencies they're not in the bag
but they have big leads in the both
those places that they've held for a
long time
stacked up big enough majorities for
those places to be considered seats that
they can hold which leaves lots of town
communities small medium-sized towns
across the UK which will be the focus of
the campaign do you think that some
people feel forgotten in towns yeah it's
an important point that we we forget how
people feel we often talk about how
people think and how people behave
actually how they feel involves their
behavior their political behavior so if
they feel a place that where they live
is declining and they're pessimistic
about its future I personally believe
that has an impact on who they would
choose to vote for or whether they vote
at all the government will bring forward
proposals for an early election again
tomorrow but it's very unlikely to get
the 2/3 of MPs needed to back it the
people are very North might have to wait
a little longer before casting their
votes